after a series of scandals Facebook is
under fire again over newly released
documents that shown a parent patter a
pattern of exploiting minors for their
parents money more than a hundred pages
of documents it's all part of a 2012
lawsuit were released last night they
show Facebook was aware children spent
large sums of money on game apps without
parental consent the suit alleges the
social media giant made it difficult for
parents than to get their money back
Carter Evans spoke with the mother
behind the lawsuit what was it like when
you open that bill it was very shocking
Glennis Bohannon let her 12 year old son
use her credit card to play the game
ninja saga on Facebook but that initial
charge of $19.95 mushroom into nearly a
thousand dollars I wanted to know what
my son was doing because I had told him
I was only a one-time transaction he's
like I'm not using your card what he
didn't realize was that Facebook had
stored his mom's credit card and was
charging it as he played the game I said
show me what you're doing so there was a
little stack of coins and it was get low
and it would blink at him
and he would hit it and I'd go burn and
the coins would shoot up again and
that's how it was charging your card and
nothing no symbol of my Visa card
no symbol 1995 with the dollar symbol
nothing just like he had told me this
practice was widespread according to
newly released court documents it was
known at Facebook as friendly fraud
meaning a miner was using an app on a
parents or grandparents account Bohannon
filed a lawsuit after finding it
impossible to reach Facebook for a
refund the case ultimately grew into a
class-action her attorney John Parker
did they know this was catching up kids
in a in a in a net here there's no way
that they didn't know that these
transactions were originating from
Facebook accounts that were assigned to
minors newly released internal emails
filed in court showed that in 2012
Facebook analyzed refund requests on
another game Angry Birds and found that
more than 90 percent were because of
friendly fraud it says that in nearly
all the cases the parent didn't think
the child would be allowed to buy
anything with
their password or authorization first I
think it was all driven by a greed and
money one deposition shows Facebook
employees were reluctant to reduce this
friendly fraud because it would likely
also reduce the company's overall
revenue according to court documents the
company calculated the between 2008 in
2014
minors under 18 made purchases on
Facebook totaling more than 34 million
dollars I felt that this could be a
family's rent or the car payment or
their grocery money and that this was
wrong
Bohannon's case was settled in 2016 in a
statement Facebook says we routinely
examine our own practices and in 2016
agreed to update our Terms and provide
dedicated resources for refund requests
related to purchases made by minors on
Facebook what do you want people to know
after all that you've been through with
this just be very careful they'd change
some of their practices but initially
when they went into buying and selling
things on Facebook they didn't have
proper safe practices for CBS this
morning I'm Carter Evans